hello everyone is the third and final
day of e3 2015 and I'm joined on stage
by Danny O'Dwyer sophomore I'm good how
are you I'm doing good hey there are a
lot of hot games at e3 its front to back
hot games but one of the hottest is not
being shown on the e3 show floor behind
closed doors yeah that's true me and
Andy Berman we're lucky enough to spend
some time playing no man's sky yeah I
played it is a real video game that's
good because I'm still don't know what
is please explain to me what is and if
it's any good so I guess no one's guys
it's yeah it's like I've shown it off
and people are really sure like how big
is it how small it seemed like what
scale are we talking about here
basically kind of plays like Minecraft
and that you start off you don't have
many resources you have like a gun that
can like shoot like the most basic like
structure and pull resources from it
right and they take that resource and
then you decide to either you know use
it to combine it with another resource
and you can sell that and get more money
or you can you know use it to upgrade
your ship or upgrade your you're gone
and get it better gone or upgrade your
suit and then use those abilities to
kind of explore seem right you get money
for everything in this game you get
money for exploring you get money for
like finding planets you get money for
when you get into the planets forex
scanning the wildlife and adding that to
Atlas which is like the global database
right which everyone pulls from so like
if you find enough stuff on a planet and
you can rename that planet and that'll
be the same for anyone else playing the
game but it's not at least it's not a
game we were going to be running into
other players like you never run into
other players even if you went to the
same spot as far as I know it's all just
feeding into the central database which
and everyone else is pulling from okay
and I mean games like minecraft they
don't really have a narrative but when
halo games first introduced it they say
indicate that there will be some sort of
focus on this game like everyone's
trying to get to the center of the water
and that's not something we're gonna see
in for a really long time probably
where's any indication that we're
getting little bits of story in the lead
up there or you know while you're
exploring is there something that kind
of hooks you into a narrative and pulls
you along yeah so they've think they've
been kind of like intentionally
obfuscating exactly what the narrative
is but in the same way that like they're
not saying like oh you can make this
many guns actually you can make probably
millions because of all the different
components you
we'll talk about that later and but you
in terms of narrative stuff like there
is no cutscenes there are no dialogue
trees there's no like people you're
meeting is no AI you're talking to right
if the game is a set of systems that you
interact with their animals el chaar Pat
you and there are like Raiders that
might shoot at you or cargo guys who
might like want your help and to like
protect from the raiders but all this
stuff is it's kind of implied in the
same way of life minecraft like the
wider narrative of like the most
interesting thing about Minecraft was
that after a while it was like you know
things like hair O'Brien like doug is
this character that exists in the world
some people have seen it some people
haven't and you know like how how are
certain characters link to other
characters and had it a different like
ecologies work and I'm I don't think
it'll be as basic as that I think
they're actually putting in a lot of
like little nods and winks that people
will be uncovering as you go along but
it definitely is it seems like there is
an overarching like they have it's not
just a random universe like minecraft
there's a purpose to everything but
they're just not telling anyone so I you
have to get to the center of universe
and I think when all the gamers get to
play this game whenever it comes out and
I think what will happen is we will
create the story of one that game is I
don't think they're going to be employed
they're not saying like oh yeah it's a
it's Jesus is in the middle of universe
or an ice cream is or you know whatever
I don't think it's like that we were
discussing this yesterday we came up
with this crazy idea that because
players never meet yeah I shouldn't like
if the if the kind of like the end game
was the moment which plays actually meet
for the first time and it just kind of
creates this explosive ring that
destroys everything but what I'm most
interested in the way the game is kind
of like the chance of nothing happening
yeah for the longest time and then
something awesome finally happening is
that something that you know they're
kind of playing up because they took
they talked about it briefly on on the
press conference Tony's press conference
where he was like I'm gonna go into this
planet maybe maybe something's good
something good will be there maybe not
was that a legitimate thing that happen
or some kind of script it because
developers have been known to be like oh
I'm gonna do something crazy here maybe
I'll be you know the one thing they
scripted there was that they said that
wasn't like the the upload point was
going to be there right they made that
happen in the key or whatever but apart
from that yeah I was totally random and
so I got to play the game and I'm like
[ __ ] I better pick a good star like I
zoomed the house and I went through all
the star systems and you got that
feeling of like complete like in
significance because you're
looking at all these star systems and
we're all just on this tiny little blue
rock and roll gonna die and then when I
picked 1i but then I was like oh which
planet will I go down to and I picked
this one and like zoomed in my warp jets
and then like I I kind of fluff the
landing actually I'm planning on the
side of a mountain because I didn't
trust the thrusters on went in and and
that the planet i found was kind of [ __ ]
like there's there's a couple of chicken
be saunas and there was a there was a
space station and then I handed the
controls to Andy and he shot all them
them the space cops turned up base cops
yeah so this is thing like lots of the
planets that have wildlife on them have
these sentinels which are basically
robots that and will turn up if you
start messing with on it so I think
that's probably something in the
narrative but we don't know that and the
interesting thing about those is that it
works like GTA you basically have a five
star system in the top of the top right
of the of you I and the more you do the
bigger sentinels come you can shoot
those sentinels and use their you know
carcasses for trade as well as you can
just go down to a planet and
intentionally just stir up [ __ ] is
really interesting they've never alluded
to that it's the most gaming mechanical
thing we've ever seen and another thing
that happened to me actually when we
took off from that planet was that there
was some traders I saw them when we were
going in but when we were leaving the
planet's atmosphere there was some
traders going past and a bunch of them I
guess Raiders or whatever like warped in
and started attacking the traders one of
them the cargo hold blew open it a bunch
of cargo intact and then after a while
the trader realized oh we can't win this
fight and just warped out and before the
Raiders got the cargo Sean like swooped
in and like picked up a bunch of all
last night so like it's it's that type
of game i think it's like it's beautiful
its moment to moment i think people's
expectations need to be brought down a
little bit in terms of like this isn't
like a this isn't it a triple a gay this
is this is a super well made indie game
yeah this is a it looks incredibly looks
really good it looks better i think in
the sort of the space stuff the stuff on
the planet looks a little bit rough
around the edges obviously they're not
releasing it for a long time yet and but
I I think it's I think it's I think it's
gonna be real Instagram I think the
people who stay with aunty made a good
point people you stick with this and
enjoy what keep playing it you'll get
out what you put in
it's good to kind of make sure you lower
expectations i think a lot of people are
going and expecting the kind of like
crafted experience in something like
mass effect yes I'm not with the combat
and the kind of like dialogue treatment
like every like race is intricately
detailed and although there might be
some you know information on the types
of monsters and Wildlife Act it's not
going to be as interconnected and as
like set in stone as something like mass
effect and I think that's kind of cool
yeah well loads of those games so this
is I get a different type of game just
when we'll be able to play it that was
the problem that is the problem any
indications the one thing Sean said was
that if I'm at e3 next year I'll go
crazy so that kind of made me think oh I
wonder if that means my guys might try
and get it out before this time next
year I think they would the sense i get
from the campuses they really want to
say ray stage I think that they're under
I feel like the team also doesn't want
to say really stay because then they
have that pressure and they have a lot
of expectation on that's what I think
what's going to happen is or I think by
the end of this year we would definitely
know when it's coming it i think
probably I wonder if gamescom might be
when we see it yeah but to be like if I
was a betting man and I don't like
betting on these things because I get
them wrong letters of the as often as I
got them right I think we'll see in the
next 12 months I think excellent oh
thank you for joining me to talk about
no man sigh oh actually one more thing
we've got one other thing I didn't talk
about okay we'll talk about it on the
point tomorrow so watch the point on
gamespot com tomorrow have a fun little
thing actually about Nolan sky there you
go and for more III coverage keeper
gamespot
you